Oui, quand on le regarde de cette façon, nous y sommes
Quand on le regarde contre le café
Ukraine Russie Crimée c'est plutôt ça
De notre côté se trouvent la Roumanie et la Bulgarie
Car nous n'avons jamais été complètement confrontés
Nous restons pour que le vent soit fort d'en haut
Quand ça souffle, les mines là-bas
On peut dire que ce n’est qu’une question de temps avant qu’il n’arrive.
[Musique]
je
Ça fait 10 jours et dix jours, resserrons le carré
Nous sommes sortis ensemble un jour en dix jours et aujourd'hui aussi
Alors nous l'avons laissé maintenant
Il a dit : Peut-être que quelque chose va nous arriver
Il arrive que les profits proviennent de biens pour une raison quelconque.
Ne soyons pas Candan, ne soyons pas Candan
nous sommes partis nous avons quitté nos amis
Quatre-vingt-dix pour cent sont ici en ce moment
s'abonner
À
Bien sûr, c'est ma nuit
On dit que l'Ukraine équivaut à des chaînes
Est-ce que je dis qu'ils sont brisés et dispersés ?
Je veux mais si le temps s'y plonge
Il faut donc qu'il passe par ce détroit.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ces mines sont dans la mer Noire
Un courant traversera cette gorge
Ça a l'air si parfait, y en a-t-il ?
[Musique]
y a-t-il
s'abonner
que fais-tu